as you of course already know wgo
director-general dr. Ted resident on
KBS's has reconvened an emergency
committee under the international health
regulations on the Ebola virus disease
in the Democratic Republic of Congo
the committee will ascertain whether the
outbreak constitutes a public health
emergency of international concern
obviously and what recommendations
should be made to manage the outbreak in
case this will be the third meeting of
the Committee on this outbreak the first
one was on 17 October and the second
last year and the second one on 12 April
on 11 June the Ugandan Ministry of
Health confirmed the case of Ebola in
Uganda the patient a five year old from
the Democratic Republic of Congo has
since died the grandmother or so this
death was on 12 June in the morning I
think the grandmother the 50 year old
grandmother of that little boy also died
the same day so this makes two deceased
cases in that in that cluster a third
confirmed case the three old brother of
that little boy has been repatriated
voluntarily and that's important on
their own wish to DRC from Uganda with
parts of the family in order to receive
treatment at the Ebola treatment center
in beany
Uganda does have experience in managing
Ebola for quite a while the country has
been preparing extensively as you just
stated also over the past month for
potential cases the Ministry of Health
also responded quickly on on this
situation with rapid sharing of
information between the health
authorities their health workers and
recognizing Ebola symptoms into patients
and quickly providing them after with
the health care so preparedness and
early action are very vital in an to
container outbreak early as as you all
know
[Music]
we're a hospital it is a general
district or petrol in the car say
district the only refer hospital
nika's district as a government and
there are other hospitals like Karen
Baraka Gondo but this place was
specifically selected to manage an
outbreak that would happen Lucas I see
[Music]
[Music]
when this epidemic came of course nobody
could predict that is happening it came
while other patients were there
unfortunately enough the skills we had
we managed to discover that this way a
suspect and immediately we had to
isolate them isolation is the best
method of protecting other patients from
getting diseases or nosocomial disease
[Music]
[Music]
we may need a physician and you find
that we don't have a physician but do
hope we shall get one you will find that
all the supplies may not be adequate
enough to our patients we have a lot of
patients here so the drugs may not be
enough for a patient see very very space
for examples I talked about the
isolation for epidemic patients is not
adequate
but I think we need that [ __ ]